all right the vice president back from
her trip as the president sets off for
his big trip about a whole lot of
controversy and she's getting it from
both sides
on why she didn't visit the border
itself griff jenkins into rio texas with
more on that griff
hey neil what the vice president would
see if she came here
is that the smuggling operations don't
stop this is the rio grande river it is
the u.s mexico border between del rio
texas
and mexico on the other side you can see
some activity
over there just about 30 minutes ago we
had about a half a dozen venezuelans
crossed now look at this tight shot
we've just got for you
the gentleman in the white shirt
crouching there that is the smuggler
that's moving him i tried to talk to him
here in the water about 30 minutes ago
but he didn't want to talk to me i just
asked him if more people were coming
he said yes so we expect more crossings
to happen
any moment now from the mexico side to
come across here
to this private property that we've been
at all day long now we went for an
exclusive boat ride
along with the border patrol chief for
this sector austin scare o'neill
yesterday and it was quite eye-opening
crossings happening
all day long in broad daylight and he
talked to me as we witnessed a crossing
about the dangers the migrants face
take a listen to this and
god forbid one of these babies gets you
know dropped in the water and they can't
get to them
so far this year we've rescued almost
1300 people
sadly we've had about 49 die to either
exposure or drownings
it happens this river is a dangerous
place
and neil i mentioned that property owner
her name is
marcia morgan she lives in this house
right here on the bank she's frustrated
with what she's been seeing
and i asked her if she wants the vice
president to visit here's what she said
you know i wish they would but you know
i know they have no intention
of doing so and honestly
i don't feel like them coming here that
they they would make any changes but
they need to foresee
what the impact of their choices you
know are going to cause
five ten years down the road
and neil i don't know if you can see
this actually right now the uh
smuggler is coming over towards us i'm
just going to take a moment
and ask him a few questions hola come
here to us
more
[Music]
migrants
okay well neil he's not saying anything
about how much he's getting paid or if
he has a message for president
biden but he does say that more people
are coming
not entirely sure why the smuggler is
sitting in the middle of the river here
we're going to continue to monitor it
and bring it to you as we get it neil
incredible uh he's not exactly hiding
all right
thank you very very much chris jenkins
you ever wonder where a lot of these
folks go